I've been playing Star Wars Jedi
Survivor and personally I absolutely
love it but let me give you a couple of
pros and cons to see if you might want
to dive into Pro it is absolutely
stunning and with way more environmental
detail than the previous game Khan
directly related to that is that I did
have a fair share of frame rate drops
Pro it is much faster and more fluid
than Jedi fallenwater I feel like the
combat animations and the traversal
animations are all so tight and flow
together so well that it just strings
you along at such a fast speed and it's
actually really hard to put down con
potentially depending on how you look at
it I actually think it is a little bit
easier than the previous game you start
off with most of the abilities that the
previous game have which I actually
really appreciate but I certainly felt
like I didn't have to be quite as
precise with my Parry timing or with my
lightsaber in general pro it has this
new cool thing called stances kind of
like goes to sushima or for Honor well
basically instead of just swapping
between your lightsaber and your dual
lightsaber there are now a couple of
different lightsaber types and different
stances and it really makes you think in
a way that I really enjoyed go into the
story and the characters are maybe a
little bit predictable and a little bit
cliche but this is a very minor con